bonjour à tous
merci de participer à cette rencontre
dont je rappelle que
vous représentez ici
en tant que partie émergée de l'iceberg
la partie immergée qui est beaucoup plus
importante puisque cette rencontre est
diffusée sur Internet quelle sera comme
vous le savez reprise dans nos actes
dans les actes de ces rencontres et donc
merci de votre présence je vous rappelle
la règle du jeu que Jean-Pierre Riou et
l'équipe qui l'entoure et que je
remercie et moi nous avons fixé
c'est-à-dire
aussi près que possible de 30 minutes
d'exploser initial et de 30 minutes de
discussion ensuite de manière à finir
un peu après 20h puisqu'il est un peu
après 19 heures
je suis très heureux que Olivier Mongin
est accepté de participer à cette
rencontre
j'ai plusieurs raisons d'exprimer cette
cette satisfaction et ce bonheur
la première c'est que Olivier Mongin est
le responsable d'une revue qui a joué
dans le courant de pensée dont nous
sommes je vais employer un mot un peu
extra banal les épigones de nous sommes
la figure actuelle l'avatar on peut dire
ça d'un courant de pensée pour lequel la
revue Esprit fondée par Emmanuel Mounier
dirigé de pendant des années très
importantes par mon ami Jean-Marie
Domenach
on en est maintenant la génération
suivante puisque Nicolas Domena comme
vous le savez le fils de Jean-Marie
Domenach est un journaliste important de
Marianne et que Jean-Luc d'omnack et
fils aîné de Jean-Marie et le très grand
sinologue il viendra
d'ailleurs nous faire une conférence un
de ces jours et c'est une c'est un
courant de pensée qu'on appelait
je sais pas si ça se dit encore
aujourd'hui
personnalise et communautaire et pour un
certain nombre d'entre nous nous avons
beaucoup réfléchi ou en tout cas gloser
sur ce que personnalise voulait dire et
communautaire corrigée et donc c'est une
c'est une famille esprit et la revue
phare de ce courant de pensée même si
les choses ont beaucoup changé avec les
directeurs successifs
Paul Thibault qui vous a précédé
immédiatement et vous même ça c'est la
première raison
la deuxième donc de satisfaction la
deuxième raison c'est que
je vais prendre le risque de de dire ce
que je ressens de votre pensée c'est que
vous vous intéressez à une question qui
est pour beaucoup d'entre nous central
qui est
la question de la civilisation que je
pourrais dire autrement
comment humaniser les humains
et comment humaniser les humains dans
les temps que nous vivons aujourd'hui
qui sont des temps
par le changement d'échelle par la
circulation sans limite de la formation
par la matérialisation d'une très grande
partie du monde par le fait qu'on
considère que la question matérielle et
la plus importante
cette
planète sur laquelle on a l'impression
que la déshumanisation des humains est
extrêmement forte et c'est l'objet de la
conférence de ce soir et
une des réponses d'Olivier monjas c'est
la ville
l'urbanité par l'urbanisation si je
pouvais risquer quelque chose c'est que
dans sur la planète comme elle vit dans
le monde comme il va dans la
globalisation comme elle se manifeste la
ville la structure
urbaine
est un des moyens de recréer ou de
d'aller vers ou de favoriser cette
humanisation des humains si je me suis
trompé dans votre pensée vous le direz
absolument voilà c'est comme tout le
monde le voit une question centrale
dans un monde où la ville est devenue le
lieu de vie de la majorité des humains
c'est la première fois dans dans
l'histoire de la planète
évidemment cette question est une
question centrale et qu'un philosophe
le alors je sais pas à quoi il faut vous
rattacher à la phénoménologie enfin bon
cette question là
est devenue une question centrale et
qu'un philosophe la prenne à son compte
dans un courant de civique c'est
évidemment très important la quatrième
et dernière et ultime raison pour
laquelle je suis heureux de recevoir les
vieux monjaille ici c'est que au
printemps dans des circonstances
politiques un peu lourde désagréable il
a fait un article j'ai trouvé
extrêmement généreux dans lequel il
expliquait que mon élection était une
chose importante et que en tout cas il
recommandait à ceux qui le lisaient de
réfléchir à cette engagement voilà
toutes les raisons j'ai essayé une
présentation succincte je suis très
heureux que Olivier Mongin soit là et je
lui donne la parole
merci beaucoup merci Monsieur bérou
merci de votre présence
très heureux d'être là ce qui est aussi
des amis Jean-Pierre Rio qui fut membres
du comité de rédaction de l'arvus esprit
je pense qu'il s'en souvient en bonne
historien qu'il est Robert Rochefort
qu'on a dû publier souvent et
certainement beaucoup d'autres gens dans
la salle puis je voudrais dire que je
suis un grand ami de Jean-Claude
Casanova qui ne l'oublions pas dirige
une très grande revue
je dis au passage que nos deux revues
sont peut-être les deux seules revues
strictement indépendantes avec une ou
deux autres dans la vie intellectuelle
française c'est-à-dire que les autres
vues sont souvent des revues d'éditeurs
etc nous sommes des petites entreprises
et Jean-Claude et le sait c'est pas
facile
vous savez parce que il y a non
seulement tout le rythme non non
François c'est pas grave il y a tous
l'héritage historiques si je puis dire
personnaliste et communautaire mais il y
a depuis presque un an une formidable
cure d'amaigrissement de la revue Esprit
n'est pas qu'il y a divisé sa pagination
par deux et qui s'est ciblé sur des
questions et pas n'importe lesquels qui
sont celles qui que très précisément
nous abordons ici
alors je répète je dis décembre 2012
le dernier numéro refaire les humanités
novembre 2012 reconquérir l'espace
public
septembre 2012 la pauvreté perdue de vue
août septembre 2012 le bip artisme
trompeur et l'égalité inégalité des
territoires et chers François juillet
dans un dossier à côté d'un dossier sur
les mirages de l'excellence enfin les
élites etc etc
fallait-il sauver le solveigrou voilà
d'Olivier Mangin voilà je n'en dis pas
plus pour l'instant bien Jean-Pierre
Riou vient avec beaucoup d'élégance de
me faire remarquer que j'avais manqué
tous mes devoirs qu'il me pardonnent
pardon merci article que je finirai
aujourd'hui sans aucun problème
je vais essayer je crois qu'à un temps
limite de jouer le jeu donc je vais plus
essayer de poser des problèmes parce que
sur toutes ces questions il y a des
on le disait que Jean-Pierre des
problèmes de langage énorme c'est comme
sur le mariage homosexuel on sait pas si
on parle de la même chose le mariage
pour tous etc il y a un problème de mots
qui touche aujourd'hui la vie politique
dans son ensemble très souvent ne fait
plus de quoi on parle et on parle
juridique où on parle technique on n'est
plus capable de débattre à l'Assemblée
nationale comme des battles et députés
que Jean-Pierre connaît bien au 19e
siècle Lamartine qui était pas le plus
grand QI du monde c'est un poète bon
c'est quelqu'un quand il discutait de la
propriété il savait qu'il jouait avec un
concept aujourd'hui on ne réfléchit plus
beaucoup alors moi je vais essayer
d'aborder la question globale locale
c'est assez lourd c'est large mais en
essayant simplement de prendre de
quelques petits problèmes mon maître
Paul riqueur disait toujours la question
c'est pas d'avoir les solutions c'est
bien poser les problèmes et moi je pense
que le la grande crise du politique
aujourd'hui et cette difficulté d'avoir
un langage
pas nécessairement commun on a le droit
de se diviser en politique mais il y a
cette ce problème donc je vais tourner
autour de la mondialisation parce que
c'est un mot qui est devenu un mot et
demi puisque mondialisation ça à
l'extérieur c'est dangereux c'est néfast
bien sûr que c'est pas nécessairement
positif je travaille sur j'ai déjà fait
un livre et j'en saurai en septembre
prochain sur la mondialisation urbaine
c'est à dire j'essaie de montrer qu'il y
a des tendances lourdes à l'échelle
mondiale qui traverse différemment les
sociétés on vit pas à Paris ou à Pau
comme à Kinshasa c'est bien évident ou
comme à Singapour etc mais on voit des
tendances lourdes qui travaillent
l'ensemble des sociétés j'ai la chance
de pas mal voyager et on discute assez
facilement en Amérique latine voir en
Chine avec les mers plus facilement
qu'ici parce qu'effectivement les
questions elles sont prises de front ça
va très vite comme vous l'avez dit alors
je vais épeler un centre de problèmes
mondialisation urbaine pourquoi parce
que je pense qu'avec la mondialisation
on est piégé aujourd'hui on a une
approche qui est strictement économique
et il faut l'avoir c'est les problèmes
d'emploi c'est les problèmes de travail
vous en avez souvent parlé mais c'est le
l'approche qui doit être prioritaire
pour le politique c'est bien évident il
faut y répondre mais l'approche
strictement économique réduit
certainement notre capacité de
compréhension du phénomène
un très bon juriste au Collège de France
maintenant Supiot dit l'approche
économique elle est importante mais on
peut tous revenir à des protectionnistes
et la mondialisation d'une certaine
manière est-ce que leur a disparu non il
n'aura pas disparu parce que ce qui
porte la mondialisation ces deux autres
phénomènes très très importants sur
lequel je vais revenir et je crois que
vous y êtes sensible ici c'est la
révolution numérique qui est
insuffisamment pensée je vais essayer de
le préciser et bien entendu c'est
l'urbanisation j'ai pas besoin
d'insister début du 20e siècle 8% de
gens qui sont urbains urbanisés
c'est-à-dire vivre en ville c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont l'urbanité et qui vivent de
manière on n'est pas là on va atteindre
70% de 2060 2070 le problème notre grand
anthropologue le voyage soit au polo en
1934 je crois
Sao Paulo 2 millions d'habitants il y
avait encore des vaches dans la rue et
c'est un anthropologue ils sont les
choses ils sont les fondamentaux parce
que on parle pas n'importe comment on
habite pas n'importe comment et il
disait ça va trop vite et ceux qui ont
l'occasion de bouger un petit peu que ce
soit Brésil Chine on voit très bien que
ça construit trop vite mais on parle de
durable toute la journée à propos de
l'urbain là on est en train de
construire des choses qui seront
difficiles difficilement durables le
problème justement de la ville tel que
vous l'avez évoqué c'est que ça puisse
durer donc le problème ça va trop vite
la vitesse on va voir que la vitesse
elle est centrales dans la révolution
justement informatique vous l'avez
évoqué à l'instant et donc révolution
numérique urbanisation j'assiste pas sur
les autres phénomènes très important
transformation du rôle de l'État
numéro qu'on vient de sortir aujourd'hui
face à l'impuissance publique pour être
un thème pour la question dans le
transformation de ce qu'elle politique
il faut bien voir que le modèle qu'on a
aujourd'hui on vient pas la Grèce pour
autant c'est le modèle de la cité-État
performante c'est le modèle Singapour
qui va prendre des variantes très très
diverses de Dubaï à des villes plus
importantes des villes moins importantes
c'est la petite cité-État reproduisait
on a assez loin de notre État national
donc
urbanisation numérique transformation du
rôle de l'État j'insiste pas sur les
problèmes culturels je reviendrai
éventuellement quand on travaille sur
l'urbain l'urbanisation difficile ça
veut pas dire que les gens habitent bien
c'est pas parce qu'il y urbanisation
qu'on habite bien c'est ma salle
problème aujourd'hui n'oublions pas que
à l'échelle mondiale aujourd'hui il y a
à peu près 60% de est-ce qu'il faut dire
habitat d'habitat informel c'est-à-dire
par rapport à nous la formelle domine ça
veut pas dire illégal l'informel domine
il faut quand même avoir ça en tête
ça veut pas dire qu'on répond pas à
l'informel ceux que ça intéresse il y a
un livre d'un Canadien qui vient de
sortir du village à la ville au seuil
traduction qui montre très bien comment
aujourd'hui il prend des exemples
partout parce qu'un journaliste français
a beaucoup de mal à faire se promener
comme ça et il essaie de montrer
parfaitement comment ça se passe et
comment ça intègre très très
difficilement alors que nous on a cette
image de la ville intégratrice
républicaine que vous avez évoqué
je pourrais donc j'insiste beaucoup
l'intérêt de prendre l'urbanisation
c'est que ça nous oblige à regarder
n'oublions pas l'économique bien entendu
mais à regarder un peu autrement ce qui
se passe et en plus ça touche
l'économique bien entendu quand vous
allez au Brésil vous voyez le maire de
récif que je connais un petit peu lui
son problème effectivement c'est de
faire venir les entreprises et donc il
faut une ville stable il faut qu'il y a
un minimum de stabilité l'économie exige
cette stabilité
c'était la première série de remarques
essayons de compliquer notre approche de
la mondialisation sachant qu'on est tous
pris dedans et j'insiste c'est quoi la
mondialisation par ailleurs ce sont des
flux portés par le numérique la fameuse
loi de Moore ça va être de plus en plus
vite vous le savez tous avec vos
machines qui vont toutes de plus en plus
vite et qu'il faut racheter en
permanence donc
nous avons donc une révolution numérique
qui est extrêmement importante et les
flux ils sont de tous ordres ils ne sont
pas que commerciaux vous le savez c'est
des flux de population donc pensez en
terme de flux c'est des flux de
communication d'image d'idées de gens
etc mais faisons attention à pas penser
que les flux mondialisés nous qui sommes
un peu étatique on aime la verticalité
vous vous êtes un historien vous savez
ce que c'est que l'État français enfin
il y a deux historiens à côté de moi la
vision étatique vous avez écrit des
histoires me semble-t-il
la vision étatique est une vision
pyramidale hiérarchique qui monte voyons
on voit très bien dans le débat sur les
collectivités territoriales
or un monde de flux est un monde
horizontal un monde horizontal il est
plein de trous il est dangereux c'est un
monde liquide liquidité il y a un auteur
pour ceux qui s'intéressent excusez-moi
je suis un peu d'intecteur de service je
donne des auteurs il y a de très grands
auteurs qui travaillent là-dessus
zingmoun baoman le présent liquide on
vit dans un monde liquide
liquidité financière bien sûr mais
liquidité maritime je vais revenir tout
à l'heure la question maritime elle est
centrales parce que c'est la question
maritime c'est les protestants c'est le
capitalisme anglo-saxon c'est pas nous
issus du catholicisme avec cette vision
de l'État je dis pas qu'il faut devenir
protestant et c'est des enjeux qui
touchent l'imaginaire c'est à ça que je
veux venir aussi l'imaginaire de la
culture politique française à laquelle
vous êtes si sensible monsieur Véro bon
les voyants qu'on est dans un monde des
flux à un monde de flux c'est un monde
où est né immergé c'est pas quelque
chose qui est au-dessus on peut pas
continuer à penser moi ici ma rue le
quartier le colloque où nous sommes là
enfin la réunion après on va passer à la
commune département région tous les
débats qu'on va avoir je terminerai
là-dessus tout à l'heure et ensuite
nation Europe et puis le monde il y aura
un monde au-dessus pas du tout le monde
on est déjà
d'où l'idée de local que beaucoup de
politiques avancent sentent bien le
comprendre souvent
dans tout local global est déjà là et si
vous le croyez pas vous prenez vos
petites machines et vous pouvez être
perdu même en haut des Pyrénées vous
pouvez est effectivement globaliser avec
Internet
j'insiste là dessus c'est que les flux
nous obligent à comprendre qu'on est
d'abord immergé le problème c'est pas de
monter comme on dit souvent dans mon
milieu de gens de l'écriture ah ou qui
sommes un peu paniqué par Internet le
livre est quand même très fragilisé
c'est un autre débat mais le problème
n'est pas d'aller du réel au virtuel
comme on et puis le problème c'est qu'on
est déjà pris dans tous ces flux
globalisés le problème c'est de revenir
en réel pour essayer de pacifier tous
ces flux d'en faire quelque chose de les
territorialiser pour ça que le débat
avenir je terminerai là-dessus le débat
à venir sur la choix de la
décentralisation sur comment
reconfigurer les territoires et
fondamental aujourd'hui tous les
territoires sont en reconfiguration
partout même chez nous la mobilité
l'emporte sur les territoires les
territoires ils sont toujours en retard
comme disait Laurent Davy qui a fait
cette excellent petit livre la crise qui
vient c'est le grand économiste des
territoires c'est le petit livre à lire
la nouvelle fracture territoriale
les territoires ils sont toujours en
retard sur les pratiques mais les
territoires ils on est au rendez-vous de
la démocratie ils organisent la
démocratie donc le débat qu'on va avoir
sur la manière de repenser les
territoires c'est l'enjeu de la
démocratie représentative il y a du
territoire parce qu'il y a de la
représentation démocratique de ça on
parle pas du tout à la revue Esprit
après sur les collectivités je pense
qu'ici il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
sur le terrain etc vous pouvez parler de
terme technique
les gens ne savent même pas ce que c'est
qu'une PCI
dont tout le monde parle toute la
journée dans les milieux le monde de
l'urbain en France c'est un monde qui
est terriblement technicisé et juridique
et qu'on a beaucoup de mal à faire
bouger je dis pas qu'il y a pas de
démocratie urbaine des grandes
métropoles il se passe des choses moi
j'ai fondé un club les métropolitaines
avec un ami qui est le patron de la
Communauté urbaine de Bordeaux Vincent
feltes il y a des métropoles
intéressantes on a un Premier ministre
qui avait une métropole intéressante
reste qu'il a du mal quand il est
premier ministre au niveau de l'État a
porté ce qui sa dynamique métropolitaine
qui est une bonne dynamique de flux
justement ça qui est très intéressant
j'arrête là dessus donc voilà un peu
première série de réflexion vous
m'arrêtez si je suis trop long essayez
de prendre le temps de comprendre et de
faire comprendre que la mondialisation
c'est pas bien sûr c'est à peu près
ennemi vous allez ça pose plein de
problèmes économiques Robert en parlerai
mieux que moi mais on est dedans c'est
la troisième mondialisation après les
grandes découvertes la Renaissance et
après la révolution industrielle on est
parti dans la révolution numérique qui
veut pas dire que l'industrie n'est plus
là on peut continuer à industrialiser
les Chinois le font etc le problème
c'est qu'on est rentré dans un autre
monde alors l'intérêt deuxième série de
problèmes et de remarques mondialisation
urbaine
on a un pays d'historien et les amis
historiens n'en voudront pas aujourd'hui
on a une pression d'une histoire au
patrimonialise les lieux de mémoire sont
étouffants Jean-Pierre m'en voudra
peut-être pas il faut devenir géographe
il faut mettre les cartes sur la table
il faut regarder ce qui se passe et là
c'est
d'ailleurs c'est Jean-Claude Casanova
qui me rappelait qu'il y a encore
quelques temps
la Greg de géographie était dévalorisée
parce qu'il y avait pas latin grec je
sais pas si tu peux confirmer ça mais
bon la géographie dévalorisée
parce qu'elle a été créé celui-ci
il y a des gens très bien et lisait
reclus et autres qui sont des géographes
à la Greg oui non pas la géographie
alors pour essayer d'être très précis
j'ai déjà dit monde liquide je voudrais
simplement c'est le deuxième série de
remarques le problème qui moi me
passionne le plus j'ai évoqué la
révolution numérique comme le moteur
le moteur il pose un problème de vitesse
on est dans un monde qui est aujourd'hui
je vais les réévoquer à plusieurs
vitesses le problème c'est savoir à
quelle vitesse vous fonctionnez et le
problème c'est qu'on passe plus d'une
vitesse à l'autre c'est comme le coup de
s'intégrer socialement autrefois on
passe plus d'une vitesse à l'autre comme
on le faisait avant il y a très bon
livre pour bien comprendre même si ici
la lutte des classes n'est peut-être pas
le dogme mais il y a un livre d'un
géographe de Lyon le Michel Dussault qui
est un ami de la lutte des classes à la
lutte des places c'est très intéressant
parce qu'il montre que justement
aujourd'hui le problème dans ce monde on
ne voit d'urbanisation difficile c'est
de trouver sa place et une place qui
engage de la mobilité trouver ça trouver
sa place veut pas dire que il y a pas de
problème après relevant de ce qu'on
appelait autrefois la lutte des donc
problème de vitesse je vais revenir je
voudrais juste très clairement sans
pouvoir mais là dessus on a pas mal
écrit ce qui se passe dans le virtuel ce
que vous faites toute la journée ce que
nous faisons
ce pas de la même manière dans le réel
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui les
questions c'est se connecter c'est avoir
accès logique de l'accès Rifkin tout le
l'organisation des territoires et
aujourd'hui liées à des connexions qui
ne sont pas que les connexions transport
restent que les connexions transport
sont décisives puisque c'est elle qui
justement permet de gérer les
différentiels de vitesse
il faut bien voir qu'aujourd'hui à
l'échelle mondiale les connexions sont
le moteur
alors pour bien comprendre vous mettez
sur la table vous regardez vous invitez
vos Michel Foucher un jour très
excellent géographe vous mettez sur la
table les nouvelles routes maritimes les
nouvelles routes aériennes etc etc vous
voyez qu'on est hors-jeu on est dans un
monde liquide aussi 90% du commerce
mondial et maritimes donc c'est pas la
vitesse la plus rapide que la plus
performante c'est ça qui est passionnant
mais c'est une vitesse parce que c'est
le mot d'Orbe que vous avez avec vos
mobiles flux tendu stock 0 si vous
voulez être riche aujourd'hui si vous
voulez être Singapour rien faut être
flux tendu stop zéro
je passe je peux parler de ça à une
heure ou deux j'ai même travaillé que
Monsieur ça se demande mais ancien maire
du Havre le grand échecs de Grand Paris
c'est pas le Grand Paris en tant que tel
c'est la capacité d'avoir été de créer
un pôle maritime qui est devait lier en
gros quand je dirais quand Rouen blocage
de Monsieur Fabius et Le Havre c'est
très important pourquoi parce que la
France est un pays mais je ne mets pas
sans compte c'est un pays d'État c'est
un pays de la terre brodelle écrit des
pages magnifiques là dessus c'est un
pays de l'intérieur
non mais ça c'est un autre problème oui
vous avez pas tort
mais ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas des
Baronnies dans les ports je sais pas
mais bon
oui vous inquiétez pas là-dessus
j'insiste là dessus parce que un des
gros problèmes pour nous est
effectivement d'être il y a des pays qui
sont des pays de l'Intérieur qui sont
sortis très bien les pays entier les
pays qui ont de la matière rare etc ou
fin fond du Kazakhstan une des villes
les plus riches de monde aujourd'hui
c'est à Stana qui une des villes les
plus corrompues une des villes les plus
hyper modernes les plus branchées
incroyables on a ce problème nous d'être
d'avoir une culture politique
extrêmement peu extrêmement peu maritime
parce que on était catholique lisez
Michelin de les connaître ça par coeur
Michelin la mer magnifique livre comme
toujours il oppose la Rochelle la ville
des protestants qui vont partir et qui
vont être à la ville de Richelieu et à
la ville de Rochefort qui sont des
villes à la Vauban pourrait dire des
villes bunker je mets pas du tout ça en
pot je dis que les problèmes dont il
faut arriver à parler c'est ça c'est ça
pourquoi
alors si vous regardez les routes
maritimes aujourd'hui quel est le port
le plus important c'est très bien de
fêter marseille capitale culturel 2013
regardez
ce qui est très important c'est de
comprendre ce qui se passe à Tanger Med
Tanger Med c'est le plus grand port qui
au nord de la Méditerranée qui
aujourd'hui draine à peu près tout le
trafic qui va partir vers l'Arabie etc
et remonter vers la vie
on est complètement déconnecté même
Barcelone maintenant est déconnecté etc
donc regardons les routes maritimes
apprenant à regarder l'écart moi je suis
pas du tout géographe de formation mais
on comprend les choses changent de
voyager après on voit très bien ce qui
se passe les routes aériennes on
comprendrait la même la même manière
Dubaï l'aéroport de Dubaï va être le
principal le principal aéroport du monde
en 2013
les voyons a donc l'intérêt de la
géographie c'est de mettre à plat un peu
les questions et de voir que les la
question de la connectivité et la
question centrale vous connaissez
riftkey vous connaissez un martiassen
c'est des gens il y en a un qui
américain l'autre il est indien c'est un
des très grand économiste qui parle de
quoi de la question de l'accès mais
l'accès ça joue à tous les niveaux et
ici aussi chez nous il y a des gens
enclavés risqués ni fait sa thèse de
départ initiale famille en Inde dans
deux villages pourquoi il y a des gens
qui vont bouger et aller jusqu'au stock
dans un village je vais pas l'autre
prenez de villages près de chez vous
pourquoi il y en a un qui bouge et pas
l'autre c'est l'accès parce que le monde
aujourd'hui il est fait de connexion à
plusieurs vitesses et il est fait donc
là je suis loin de l'urbanité dont tu
aurais mais c'est dans ce monde-là qu'il
va falloir réinventer de la ville ce que
je veux pas discuter soir ce soir je
mets un plat un peu le négatif mais la
réflexion elle doit prendre en charge le
négatif
tu as un groupe de travail avec des
politiques qui disent ah mais formidable
il faut rêver à nouveau
dis non le problème contemporain la
crise c'est pas de la blague il lance
une crise profondément intellectuelle je
m'excuse pour ceux qui peinent au niveau
du chômage et tout mais c'est une crise
de compréhension de ce qui se passe
parce qu'on ne regarde pas on n'a pas
pris sur le réel moi c'est mon point de
vue de philosophe qui aurait pu tendance
à vagabonder prenons le temps et là les
politiques qui prendront le temps
d'expliquer ce qui se passe vous verrez
qu'ils seront gagnants
bon dans quelle mesure ça peut passer
mais faut arrêter mais il s'agit pas
d'être pour ou contre des localisation
on peut être con je veux dire c'est pas
ça la question il s'agit de comprendre
où sont les dynamiques pas pour dire
c'est bien pas pour dire les émergents
c'est formidable
attention moi je vais souvent en Chine
au Brésil de pays que j'aime bien le
Brésil la Chine c'est plus compliqué
mais on nous baratine sur les couches
émergentes nous couche moyenne à nous
qui sont constitués au 19e n'oublions
pas que on aime ou pas Haussmann nous on
a inventé un urbanisme d'État qui est
très critiquable par des biens mais la
bourgeoisie 19e elle a pris ses
responsabilités là-dessus on a inventé
un urbanisme aujourd'hui quand vous
discutez avec un ami brésilien il dit
bien attention nous les poussent
émergentes on est loin de le produire
quand à la Chine je vous laisse regarder
ce qui se passe vous voyez bien que le
grand scandale qui a précédé le scandale
politique boxilight très important
shugming ville de 35 millions
d'habitants bâtir en moins de 30 ans
vous voyez ce que ça veut dire il y a
tous les produits de luxe français Pino
aurait pu s'installer là-bas sans
problème il préfère quand même Bruxelles
mais c'est une ville où le béton
s'effondre déjà on a des villes qui qui
déjà tombent non durables qui tombent
donc il faut bien voir ça c'est pas pour
dire nous on est décroché simplement
c'est pour dire qu'on a des atouts par
rapport à une réflexion sur et c'est
vrai que notre urbanité va mieux même si
il y a des tendances à la sécession la
fragmentation un peu partout on le sait
les inégalités territoriales d'Adil
monte en France il dit 2008
première crise économique mondiale on
n'a pas trop vu venir les choses parce
que l'État-providence tenait encore 2011
et c'est là vous avez bien vu des choses
venir 2011 l'état redistributeur il est
plus capable de redistribuer entre les
régions et territoires mais ça je vous
laisse vous êtes plus compétent que moi
c'était la deuxième série de remarque
que je voulais faire la troisième
globale locale je voudrais simplement
j'ai pas le temps et je suis déjà en
train de déborder dire il y a beaucoup
de scénarios possibles je vais en
prendre que deux il y a les deux
extrêmes il y a un scénario qui est
celui c'est un peu bon faut regarder
tout ça dans le détail excusez-moi la
caricature surtout que là on parle d'un
monde qui est pas directement le nôtre
Dubaï c'est très intéressant c'est une
des villes les plus globalisées
c'est-à-dire inscrite dans la globale
c'est-à-dire dans l'interconnexion des
villes globalisées à l'échelle mondiale
fragile pas fragile je rentre pas
là-dedans c'est une ville qui est
complètement coupée par rapport à la
population qui est censée y habiter qui
fait la ville d'ailleurs il y a une
coupure entre globale et le local vous
trouvez ça à peu près partout dans
toutes ce qu'on appelle les villes
branchées où les villes globales mais
c'est un concept je voulais simplement
insister là-dessus alors que le problème
de l'urbain c'est d'associer le local et
global d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est ce qu'on a fait nous dans notre
tradition
urbaine importante très marquée par
l'État à l'autre extrémité pourquoi on
parle de métropole toute la journée
aujourd'hui moi j'ai créé un club
s'appelle les métropolitaine il y a 3
ans on parlait pas de métropole
maintenant vous mettez deux agglo ça
fait une métropole
et vous avez métropole à Sao Paulo vous
allez métropole avec je donnerai pas
d'exemple pour pas me faire attraper
après il y a quelque chose qui est
devenu délirant ça veut dire simplement
qu'on découvre que les gens sont devenus
beaucoup plus mobiles et qui font
réorganiser les territoires et si on a
un certain sens quand même de la
redistribution parce que l'urbanisme au
départ inventé par Monsieur Serda à
Barcelone en 1857 et je dis pas de
bêtises ce n'est rien d'autre que
l'échange des services et la réalisation
des risques
l'urbanisme inventé à Barcelone le mot
est resté c'est l'état providence au
niveau d'une ville un point c'est tout
faut pas se tromper là-dessus donc c'est
des choses très très importantes
simplement ce que dit vous voyez vous
avez d'un côté des villes globalisées
celles qui fonctionnent le mieux et qui
sont des villes vitrines avec une
communication incroyable
s'empêchera pas connait bien le maire de
Lyon de nous montrer Lyon Confluence
comme Lyon conflit sillon confluent en
dessous de la gare de Perrache était le
quartier à l'image de tout Lyon parce
qu'aujourd'hui on sort des quartiers
vitrines on sort des morceaux d'huile
pour faire croire que toute la ville est
comme ça et là la communication elle
fonctionne très très bien dans les
milieux de mairie et tout elle est
extrêmement dangereuse vous avez des
critères d'évaluation qui viennent de
plusieurs personnes dont un dénommer
Florida qui sont prises sont utilisés
quand vous êtes merde ça au polo vous
pouvez comprendre que ça fonctionne
quand le nouveau maire du Havre mais les
critères de Florida dans son dans son
petit truc là qu'on reçoit quand on sort
de la gare on rigole un petit peu c'est
à dire c'est des autom maintenant la
question de la communication
d'attractivité joue un rôle très très
important on casse l'imaginaire et
urbain qui était porté par des habitants
en lui imposant on pourrait dire une
machine de communication enfin des
images je suis là très rapide
j'insiste simplement qu'on voit là une
coupure globale locale qui moi
m'intéresse beaucoup parce que on voit
très bien et ça c'est un problème qui va
toucher la mondialisation au terme
identité culture religion que vous
pouvez être le plus globalisé et ça n'a
rien à voir avec l'idée on a appelé les
mœurs Américaines pas du tout et en même
temps vous ne bougez pas du point de vue
de l'identité vous avez là une coupure
c'est Jacques Berck un grand
anthropologue que vous êtes qui
travaillait sur le Maghreb dans les
années 60-70 qui disait très bien faut
pas se tromper
l'hyper modernisation peut aller que la
tradition d'ailleurs on le voit un peu
aux États-Unis c'est un certain modèle
évangélique qui est très important au
passage pour ceux qui s'intéresse
partout vous avez de la casse urbaine
vous avez des évangéliques aujourd'hui
hein à l'échelle mondiale mais
allez-vous promener un Tremblay Gonesse
vous sortez de la gare RER
usine usine fermée temple évangélique
j'ai rien contre mais faut réfléchir à
ça il faut aucune enquête là-dessus on
en parle pas ben c'est religieux donc
c'est vous prenez la route de l'Estaque
à Marseille vous faites prenez je sais
plus quel numéro du bus vous avez deux
deux grandes usines fermées de temples
évangéliques là où il y a de la casse de
l'invivable de l'inhabitable il faut
bien que j'ai un petit peu de j'ai faut
que j'aille mes médicaments et
quelque part c'est ça ça joue c'est très
important
je termine pour dire tout ce que
pour dire qu'il y a un scénario qui est
moins m'intéresse beaucoup je suis pas
pour la décroissance je sais que tes
débat écologique ici joue un rôle
important vous avez beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent sur l'idée de mondialisation
par le bail renverse vous voyez ils
disent pas le local contre global ou
allons global surtout en Italie vous
avez beaucoup d'équipes d'urbanisme qui
travaillent là-dessus leur problème
c'est de dire on est dans les flux il
faut les prendre de front il faut pas
pour s'y accorder si on les connaît pas
on est on peut être que la victime et il
faut essayer de c'est ça l'idée de
métropole au sens positif il faudra
parler longuement il y a quand même pas
mal de travaux et de réflexions
là-dessus dont un monsieur ceux qui
s'occupe de Paul de Saclay qui s'appelle
pierre Veltz qui est très important si
on sait problème qui va sortir un livre
dans ces typiques Paris France monde
pour expliquer qu'il faut faire monde
france paris paris capitale en plus très
compliqué dans notre pays le pour ça que
le Grand Paris était piégé d'avance
puisque
discuter des grands Paris c'est discuter
de la capitale dans un pays de de la
cabine dans un pays où bon devant vous
je vais aussi là je suis discret c'est
des gens qui parlent de mondialisation
par le bas au sens de voir comment un
type de territoire peut décélérer peut
décélérer c'est l'idée de décélération
il faut épouser il faut le faire
longuement les questions de vitesse pour
montrer qu'on a des problèmes de
décélérateur mais le problème c'est pas
la marche ou les flux c'est pas c'est
pas Hong Kong ou un bon village un bon
village français retour au village non
le problème c'est de prendre de front
toutes les vitesses toutes les échelles
etc et de voir comment on peut créer des
territoires un peu pacifiants et là on
retrouve l'urbanité d'hier je vais
m'arrêter très vite
et je dis au passage la décélération
elle passe par deux choses
il y a au moins deux choses qui ont
besoin vous évoquiez des traditions
intellectuelles et autres il y a deux
choses qui ont besoin de la durée
c'est ce que dit très bien pierrevelt
c'est le savoir pour ça d'ailleurs tout
d'un coup l'université tiens en parler
là le Grand Paris au début on pourra pas
de l'université tout d'un coup
on se met à parler parce qu'on se
rappelle tout simplement que les villes
elles ont été faites dans notre dans
notre période fin de Moyen-Âge par des
universitaires qui étaient d'anciens
moines la plupart du temps et des
commerçants aujourd'hui moi je
connaissais bien la Colombie une ville
comme Bogota est une ville difficile qui
est en train d'être restructurée par les
pôles universitaires qui sont les
moteurs alors vous me direz c'est pas
l'université publique il y a pas tous
ces problèmes université privée donc un
capitalisme dur bien sûr mais on voit
très bien que vous avez des moteurs et
ça passe par le savoir qu'est-ce qui
exige aussi la décélération c'est la
solidarité la solidarité ça prend du
temps et la politique aussi peut-être
bon mais c'est un peu lié
moi je suis très sensible à ce problème
la vie vitesse et là en France on a des
gens qui ont beaucoup avancé là-dessus
Virilio etc qui sont des très longtemps
parce que le problème c'est pas la bonne
vitesse le problème c'est l'articulation
des vitesses si j'avais le temps je
continuerai je pourrais montrer ce qui
sera un prochain livre on est
aujourd'hui il y a un hyper urbanisme
qui est aujourd'hui de connexion autour
des gares et gare TGV essentiellement
gare TGV avion et un hypo urbanisme
qu'un proximité autour de la voiture
vous avez le problème c'est que tout ça
connecte très mal pour le comprendre
vous allez à Shanghai vous voyez la gare
Shanghai Sud qui a fait la gare Shanghai
Sud immense gare qui ressemble un
aéroport quatre niveaux on comprend très
bien que c'est un sas c'est une machine
à sélectionner les entrées n'oubliez pas
au passage que en Chine il y a encore le
coup c'est-à-dire une carte d'identité
urbaine tout le monde n'a pas le droit
encore d'être urbain c'est-à-dire non on
oublie trop ça ça a été le cas encore à
Moscou il y a pas si longtemps pour
pouvoir être dans la ville il faut
disposer et avoir les droits sociaux il
faut disposer de la carte d'identité
donc qui a fait cette guerre de Shanghai
Sud c'est Monsieur Dutilleul qui avait
l'Agence des gares quelqu'un respectable
qui a fait toutes les gares la France il
y a qu'en France où on a un architecte
qui vient des serments Félix enfin les
ponts un seul architecte avec une grosse
agence pour faire toutes les gares là on
voit ce que c'est que la centralité
c'est lui en même temps qui a fait cette
garde Shanghai qui est très intéressante
que vous comprenez que la gare la gare
qui fonctionne Hong Kong etc c'est la
garde TGV il y a pas de tgvencon le
problème n'est pas là mais c'est la gare
aéroport connexion gare aéroport et vous
voyez très bien que le rêve aussi nous
autour de gare TGV c'est la voiture
c'est à dire qu'on pourrait continuer
longtemps quelques mots quatrième série
de problèmes mais j'ai déjà débordé
c'est quand même d'accompagner comme on
peut mais vous le ferez mieux que moi
parce que vous avez plus d'idées que moi
mais je trouve qu'il y a aucun débat
là-dessus nous on a qu'une petite revue
avec des gens qui s'appellent tout sur
bain simplement de prise de position
on a un pays quand même on prend pas
beaucoup de position sur quoi que ce
soit et avec Michel Dussault et Jacques
donzelo beaucoup d'autres on dit on va
faire une revue que des éditos et des
prises de position et voilà bon surtout
alors très vite H3 de la
décentralisation ou en êtes-vous là
dessus très à moi je pense très
important
repartons du Grand Paris on voit très
bien que l'État l'État n'a pas trop
voulu lâcher d'où ascendantes d'échec je
reviens pas qu'est-ce qu'on voit se
mettre en place si on écoute madame le
branchu avec des petits morceaux qu'on
nous c'est sûr à droite à gauche
la commune va être un peu déstabilisée
elle va perdre beaucoup de ses droits de
l'urbanisme doit permis de construire
etc chacun a ses positions là dessus
de l'autre côté la région est valorisée
mais on lui colle quand même je n'ai pas
le terme technique une espèce de de
d'institutions où le les représentants
de l'État seront là donc contre la vie
des présidents de région française et
qu'est-ce qu'on nous invente là en ce
moment c'est des métropoles tout à 10
minutes c'est à dire qu'on lâche la
métropole effectivement on essaie d'en
faire moi je pense pas qu'il y a un bon
modèle je prends pas le mode bon modèle
mais on voit très bien que ça part dans
tous les sens jusqu'au sens de Lyon
c'est le cas de le dire avec ce qui
vient de se passer à Lyon qui est quand
même extrêmement intéressant puisque on
voit une espèce de découpage assez
bizarre au sein de la région
donc des grandes communautés urbaines
qui essaient de plus en plus autonome un
état qui cherche à contrôler toujours un
peu c'est l'état la Française des
communes qui vont perdre beaucoup de
leur pouvoir on est un peu moi nous on
dit c'est le millefeuille oui ça c'est
pas original on touche pas aux entités
on touche pas aux compétent on a aucune
réflexion là-dessus et autour de moi des
gens en soi-disant qui lisent beaucoup
sur les compétences je vous promets vous
vous êtes plus certains militants
personne ne sait quels sont les
compétences de telle entité alors que
c'est quand même fondamental où on et
je dirais c'est une espèce de
recomposition à la carte et sous
contrôle qui est en train de s'opérer
est-ce que c'est ce qui peut se faire de
mieux je suis pas sûr en tout cas il y a
pas de débat public important qui qui
accompagne et je termine par ce par quoi
j'ai commencé la question des
territoires
les territoires sont dangereux ils
peuvent être des freins parce que ce qui
nous intéresse c'est les gens qui
habitent pas toujours les territoires à
la française le problème aujourd'hui en
même temps c'est la reconfiguration
territoriale qui porte quand même une
certaine reconfiguration de la
démocratie ce que la démocratie
représentative qui va pas bien vous le
savez mieux que nous la démocratie
représentative elle repose sur des
quadrillages sur des configurations etc
etc donc qu'on soit récif ou ici les
problèmes sont communs avec des
tendances très très lourdes c'est ça que
je veux dire et il serait peut-être un
peu de temps de de son inquiéter un peu
plus voilà c'est tout ce que je voulais
essayer de dire très vite excusez-moi
merci de votre
bien ça ouvre
beaucoup beaucoup de réflexion et de
questions
et donc vous avez la parole pour vos
interrogations réflexions vous voulez
commencer Jean-Pierre
on a très bien compris enfin à la fois
qu'on arrive aux villes en quelque sorte
transnationales
plus de frontières et il y a une action
d'État et historique si je puis dire qui
qui s'affaiblit qui qui a moins de moins
de prix sur la réalité
alors on voit quand il voudrait ton
sentiment là-dessus on voit on voit
circuler quantité de concept flou
n'est-ce pas surtout ça on arrive
jusqu'à Villemonde là je sais pas ce que
tu ce que tu en dis et on arrive à une
espèce de fétichisme de la de la
métropole
avec l'idée que c'est à travers les
métropoles qu'on verra je dirais ce
oui c'est laborer se diffuser
s'installer et triompher finalement
toutes les évolutions décisives que ce
soit en termes de communication de
services de savoir de de et même de
créativité
je voudrais ton sentiment là-dessus
est-ce que le mot métropole est la fin
du fin parce que c'est ça qu'on nous
vend actuellement
voilà c'est des débats un peu complexes
mais comment accompagner les
présidentielles et qui sont pas
ressortis après
moi moi je
pense que par rapport à la fragmentation
actuelle aux espèces de mille-feuille
donc l'idée de métropolisation qu'on
trouve partout métropolisition ça veut
dire que ça grossit et qu'il faut se
rapprocher des lieux où ça connecte
mieux qu'ailleurs etc la métropole il y
a des gens qui disent d'ailleurs la
mondialisation n'est rien d'autre que le
phénomène de métropolisation alors le
problème c'est qu'est-ce qu'on met
dessous
alors vous avez une thèse quelqu'un
qu'on lit souvent je suis en fait un
entretien avec lui pour un prochain
numéro d'esprit monsieur Guy qui lui dit
les métros le problème qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est que de plus en plus on
va assister à une opposition entre les
métropoles qui combinent attractivité
compétitivité et puis toutes les zones
que lui appellent de fragilité et ça ça
nous a amené je reviens présidentielle à
la question du vote FN parce que c'est
ça qui est derrière en terme de débat
c'est que ceux qui seraient hors des
zones métropolitaine active nerveuse
effectivement serait les hors-jeu dans
ce qui est
parce que ça n'est pas enregistré
les deux les deux boutons rouges
on assiste à des phénomènes la réclusion
sociale devient une réclusion spatiale
c'est sûr et ça c'est quelque chose qui
colle mal avec notre propension à dire
métropolisant à tout va était et tout
ira mieux voilà moi après d'un mot
simplement je défends un peu la
thématique métropolitaine ce que en
France où les territoires j'ai bien dit
qu'il fallait les reconfigurer donc je
reste un homme on va pas faire
disparaître les territoires avec les
enjeux démocratiques en France on a mis
beaucoup de temps à prendre en compte le
problème des mobilités alors le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que les chercheurs et
souvent la mise en ligne il y a plus que
pour les mobilités il y a plus que alors
que le problème c'est repartir des
mobilités les mobilités sont tous ordres
bien sûr c'est les mobilité
résidentielle au passage les deux
régions Bretagne c'est quand même 25%
d'augmentation on dit que c'est l'appel
du littoral c'est 25% de rotation avant
crise 2005-2025 on a dit et la Normandie
rien pourquoi posez-vous la question là
il y a aussi les problèmes
d'attractivité qui sont mobilité
résidentielle mobilité dans le travail
mobilité
démographique etc etc c'est vrai que la
France a beaucoup de mal à prendre en
compte les mobilités
totalement faux et le problème c'est de
je pense que si on veut réfléchir moi
c'est tout ce qui m'a j'ai pas de
solution c'est la métropole c'est ce qui
nous oblige à réinscrire des mobilités
dans un territoire mais les mobilités
faut les prendre dans tout le Grand
Paris au débat on a pris que les
mobilités c'était quoi c'était les
mobilités de travail on partait c'était
la vision Sarkozy de la défense et on
amenait on voulait amener via le Grand 8
tous ces gens à Roissy direct alors que
le problème de la mobilité pour le
citoyen c'est mobilité travail résidence
que sache c'est la question centrale
pour tout le monde on n'a pas pris ça en
place mobilité je prends un autre terme
les connexions alors est-ce qu'on avait
arrivé au début du Grand Paris ce qu'on
s'intéressait beaucoup à ça tous les
directeurs d'hôpitaux amis
mais nous n'existe pas on n'est pas des
connexions je fais exprès de tout d'un
coup on découvre aussi que les musées
c'est important on découvre que
l'université c'est important moi je suis
dans le groupe avec Jamel clouch qui
s'occupe du projet tout d'un coup la
mairie de Paris se passionne pour ce
qu'ils appelaient encore le Grand
Quartier Latin c'est là où je vais quand
même faire l'éloge de la métropole parce
qu'ils avaient pas compris que les
étudiants ils vivaient plus à
Saint-Germain-des-Prés là il retrouve
les marques et tout ce que vous voulez
c'est quand même incroyable d'imaginer
que la mairie de Paris en était assez
division du grand quartier et nous les
la métropole ça voulait dire simplement
mais décentrez-vous un peu regardez
ailleurs et je m'arrête après la
métropole de la défendrait où on peut
quand même avoir une vision de la
métropole qui est une vision je dirais
plus mutualisante qui revient à ce qui
était l'esprit de l'urbain quand on a
créé l'urbanisme avec Serda voilà alors
est-ce qu'il faut se bagarrer sur les
mots et non ce que je vois c'est dans
les projets le branchu c'est que
maintenant il y a des tonnes de mètres
chacun va faire sa métropole
on est à métropole à la carte
c'est c'est assez bizarre
on parle très fort Robert
parce que c'est absolument passionnant
ce que ce que tu nous as dit moi il y a
une chose alors puisque tu m'as envoyé
la balle en tout cas au niveau des
économistes il y a une chose qui me
semble absolument fondamentale et qui
doit être au coeur de ta réflexion par
rapport à la question de la ville
aujourd'hui de la métropole c'est le
conflit entre l'ancienne économie qui
est une économie de la propriété et une
nouvelle économique et l'économie de
l'usage et on voit bien comment
aujourd'hui la la mondialisation par les
villes nous fait basculer d'une économie
de la propriété une économie de l'usage
on peut prendre pour que ce soit très
concret deux ou trois exemples
j'entendais encore ce matin qu'on disait
que à Paris on ne peut plus acheter son
logement donc on est plus dans le mythe
d'acheter son logement
dans beaucoup de grandes villes c'est le
cas de Paris c'est le cas de Londres etc
on chasse la voiture la voiture
bienvenue maintenant la propriété de la
voiture est devenue quelque chose de de
presque d'interdit et on leur on la
remplace par des logiques d'usage qui
peuvent d'ailleurs être à la fois
mutualisé mais avec un usage
individualisé quand on pense aux Autolib
ou visites de cette nature ça c'est
quand même une révolution très forte qui
incorpore d'ailleurs je pense que tu en
as pas fait pour convaincu des nouvelles
solidarités dans l'usage des produits
eux-mêmes si on prend l'exemple du
logement la colocation et la
cohabitation qui revient en force
évidemment fondée sur un principe de
rareté introduit quand même des
nouvelles formes de mutualisation c'est
pareil sur l'utilisation de laver du
vélo de la voiture etc et c'est quelque
chose qui est vrai sur beaucoup beaucoup
d'objets donc vraiment nous avons
d'ailleurs essayé un peu de le porter
pendant la campagne présidentielle ici
aussi même si c'est un thème qui est
difficile à faire émerger comme un thème
grand public mais
l'économie de demain est une économie
différente les flux dont tu as beaucoup
parlé amène aussi à une conception de
flux et à plus une conception de stock
quant à la gestion des personnes et des
familles vis-à-vis des choses alors ce
qui me frappe beaucoup c'est il me
semble mais je suis pas du tout assez
compétent là-dessus mais l'intuition que
j'ai c'est que les grandes métropoles
qui sont encore en construction
continuent à faire vivre auprès de leur
population le mythe de l'économie de la
propriété et ne bascule pas
immédiatement dans le sel de dans celle
de l'usage je je regardais ce matin pour
un voyage en Chine que quelques-uns ici
on prépare il y a 5 millions de voitures
à Pékin la dernière fois que j'étais à
Pékin il y en avait déjà beaucoup moins
mais il y a 5 millions de voitures une
pollution permanente et en tout cas à
Pékin je sais pas si c'est pareil à
Shanghai on continue à être dans le
process de permettre aux classes
moyennes chinoise d'aller acheter leur
logement dans la périphérie donc on est
sur l'idée d'acquérir son logement de
l'acheter donc je voudrais que tu me dis
si je me trompe ou pas en disant que
quand même dans le rapport au temps et
l'ancienneté où l'A plutôt récent des
des grandes villes on est un peu dans
peut-être dans ce piège de de ne pas
être au clair sur l'économie de la
propriété qui me semble quand même
maintenant devenu assez archaïque versus
l'économie comment dire de l'usage qui
ne règle pas tous les problèmes et puis
en plus l'usage suppose quand même que y
ait une propriété en amont cette
propriété qui qui l'organise mais c'est
un problème important juste un tout
petit détail j'avais pas réfléchi à ça
mais effectivement du tilleul et le
grand architecte des gars et je pensais
quand même temps Paul André est quand
même le grand architecte des aéroports
pardon
sa femme c'est Madame Chopinet pour ceux
qui ne savent pas
mais
Paul André aussi qui est un Français qui
est un grand spécialiste est un grand
architecte des aéroport alors je me
demandais est-ce que ça veut dire que
finalement les Français nous est-ce
qu'on a est-ce qu'on a une force une
spécificité sur l'architecture de ces
grands endroits de connurbations que
sont maintenant les aéroports les grands
aéroports les grandes gares ah mais ça
c'est intéressant mais bien sûr il y a
un lien entre les ces grands projets et
la formation à la française ingénieur
etc et nous ce qu'on aime c'est les
connexions
mais c'est un lien qui passe par le
train plus que plus que par l'avion
parce que moi je suis dans un groupe là
sur les mobilités à la SNCF c'est le
numéro 2 Azema qui est un type très
malin m'a fait comprendre ça je dis
pourquoi le train par exemple nous on
TGV pourquoi finalement aux États-Unis
Amérique latine les trains et les
utilisent très peu il me dit simplement
il y a que les pays a été à Fort
conduite
pourquoi parce que le train ça vaut très
cher c'est ce qu'il faut le plus cher
entretien et puis en plus qu'on a un
personnel quand on comprend que le
personnel l'infrastructure ça peut
bloquer tous les transports enfin après
la guerre de Gaulle a peut-être pas
compris que pour bloquer les transports
celui qui bloquait les transports a le
pouvoir on a pris le pouvoir quand même
en Bolivie avec les blockhaus on n'a pas
je vous avais oublié le nom du président
là excusez-moi il a pris le pouvoir avec
les beaux vous connaissez qui
connaissent la base qui pour moi une des
villes les plus fascinantes du monde
vous avez 1000 m de dénivelé à 3000
entre l'aéroport qui est à 4000 et la
ville
suffit de bloquer la route qui monte et
l'aéroport vous prenez le pouvoir
la question des infrastructures est
extrêmement importante faut jamais
oublier que ce qui vaut le moins cher
c'est un avion c'est l'avion vous pouvez
qu'une petite piste d'atterrissage faire
des la viande en mettant c'est ce qui
pollue plus donc on a un petit problème
là parce que c'est pas l'énergie propre
mais ça bien sûr faudrait alors juste
d'un mot parce que tu touches une
question fondamentale et économie de la
propriété économie d'usage moi je dois
pas la disparition de l'économie de la
propriété ça veut pas dire que il y a
pas d'usage qui se met à côté et que la
grande question pour nous pour l'avenir
du monde c'est effectivement c'est cette
question de la propriété et à bien
approprié la question centrale qu'elle
accès au logement et ça nous à la
française on a fait ça par la un peu par
l'État social les cités etc et puis mais
en même temps vous connaissez tous mieux
que moi l'histoire de des aides avec
toutes les celliers etc
est fait pour favoriser cet axe
approprié puis je vous rappelle quand
même que la crise de 2008 se primes se
touche le logement la question de si
urbanisation généralisée c'est quand
même pour la plupart des gens c'est de
pouvoir vivre des samans et qui va qui
va leur fut ils en sont pas à discuter
d'économie d'usage et le grand baratin
était chinois qui seraient déjà dans le
durable faire des chinois
ils essaient de répondre moi j'étais au
moment de Shanghai la mairie de Paris et
la région avait fait un colloque c'était
extraordinaire parce que effectivement
le colloque c'était pour expliquer au
directeur de Shanghai de l'urbanisme
arrêtez de nous polluer soyez sympa
calmer un peu le jeu etc le gars il est
resté 10 minutes il a dit j'ai autre
chose à faire moi il y a du boulot hein
et après vous alliez voir l'expo
française je dis ça de c'est une pure
anecdote mais on comprend tout l'expo
française première étage Renault
deuxième étage Peugeot 3e étage acheter
nos voitures mais ne polluez pas top
terminé si on a ce discours là si on a
ce discours là on sera perdant parce
qu'ils sont très malins pendant toute
expo à Shanghai ils ont dit il y a une
île au-dessus qui s'appelle shanking qui
sera Lille l'écologie qui sera la grande
île écologique de de la région etc le
lendemain de l'expo le projet de Lille
écologique était annulé bon voilà nous
ce qui nous ferait peut-être du bien de
temps en temps c'est ma position
personnelle c'est de savoir annuler des
projets c'est un autre débat parce que
sur toutes ces questions nos ingénieurs
et tout moi je vois bien avec le
problème avec le problème cher à
Monsieur Berrou qui est celui de la
dette qu'il a mis quand même en annonce
on voit très bien comment l'eau
fonctionnaire à la française ingénieur
il nous rebalance du grand projet de
tous les côtés il n'y a pourquoi parce
qu'il passe pas la dette hein c'est pas
parce que c'est pas on a un très gros
problème là-dessus c'est comme pour les
partenariats privés publics s'agit pas
de les mettre tous en cause mais on a
quand même un très gros problème est-ce
qu'on a est-ce qu'on a discuté
Notre-Dame-des-Landes sérieusement
oublions les trucs politiques on
pourrait compte est-ce qu'on a une
démocratie délibérative je dis même à
l'arrivée esprit est-ce qu'on était
capable de faire un dossier de discuter
de ça est-ce qu'on est capable de
discuter intelligemment avec des experts
oui
démocratiquement est-ce qu'il faut
continuer la ligne Lyon-Turin quand on
voit effectivement le projet quand on
sait qu'on est capable de faire du frais
de ferroviaire et qu'on dit que c'est
pour le frais de ferroviaire que ça va
être intéressant c'est quand même un peu
exagéré on ne discute pas de ces
choses-là et là c'est l'eau reste très
éthique
c'est des positions personnelles bien
sûr merci merci beaucoup moi j'ai tout à
fait aimé ce que vous avez dit et je
voudrais bondir sur trois trois petits
sujets rapidement le premier c'est sur
la mondialisation vous avez décrites
juste titre sur mon liquide dont vous
parlez très très bien et la
métropolisation en fait il y a quand
même une métropolisation à deux niveaux
dans le monde entier c'est-à-dire qu'on
a le centre des métropoles qui sont des
endroits vivants formidables et puis on
a les quartiers périphériques on a les
banlieues on a les ghettos on a les
misères on a les Africains qui quittent
leur terre pour rejoindre des villes on
a les campagnes rurales le monde rural
en Chine qui aussi se désattifie qui va
à la ville et qui fait de la pauvreté
beaucoup de la très grande pauvreté et
donc il y a cette question là aussi dans
les métropoles ça c'est premier point et
je pense qu'il faut qu'on l'aborde on a
deux types enfin on a deux vitesses dans
les métropoles la deuxième question vous
avez parlé du triptyque alors dans les
deux sens un monde France Paris Paris
France monde et curieusement vous n'avez
pas dit Europe je pense
que vous allez me dire pourquoi
c'est ma question c'est vrai quand on
regarde la carte des trafics maritimes
on s'aperçoit que l'Europe n'est plus
centre du monde je veux dire on est bien
on est bien d'accord globalement je veux
dire mais je voudrais que nous disiez
vous nous disiez en quelques mots quel
est votre vision de l'Europe dans ce
dans ce monde là comme ça en évolution
comment vous la voyez aujourd'hui et
puis je voudrais ensuite revenir
troisième réflexion à France et à Paris
moi j'ai le sentiment qu'on est dans un
monde dans un pays extrêmement
conservateur du point de vue de ces de
ces de ces de son organisation et de son
architecture institutionnel local
régional que de ce point de vue là il
faudrait une vraie révolution et que je
ne sais pas si cette révolution est
possible dans un état culturellement qui
est centralisé au point où est l'état
français et la France aujourd'hui donc
ça c'est une question je pense qu'il
faut une nouvelle architecture Instit
utionnelle que le millefeuille
institutionnel veut dire plus personne
ne sait qui fait quoi que on accumule
les compétences et que tout ceci devient
inefficace incompétent extrêmement
coûteux et pas démocratique
que ceci vaut pour l'ensemble de nos
territoires et puis comme je suis
parisienne évidemment la question du
Grand Paris nous taux looping tous que
ce magnifique projet de Paris Le Havre
des grands architectes étaient
effectivement extrêmement intéressant
que au fond le Grand Paris malgré tous
les discours il en est nulle part que
Paris est toujours cette ville très très
bunkérisée bon d'architecture et
mentalement je veux dire bunker que je
ne vois pas bien l'évolution des choses
que vous en disiez un mot et que je suis
frappé du fait que Robert parlait des
grands architectes français on a des
grands architectes il me semble qu'on a
pas de grands urbanistes je voudrais que
vous me donniez aussi votre point de vue
là dessus
sur les architectes
avec lui etc on a trop de starchitectes
c'est ça le problème c'est-à-dire des
gens qui se vendent très bien à
l'étranger et les mêmes qu'il a nous
font du social et tout vont être très
sympas je peux vous dire quand il
travaille au Maroc sur le front de mer à
Casablanca c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose là il est bon parce que on a un
problème on a quand même un très gros
problème de l'architecte à la je vais
vous dire pourquoi parce que les
Français en France d'ailleurs moi
j'enseigne école nationale du paysage de
Versailles
typique c'est quoi le paysage en France
paysage on découvre le site très
important ces questions n'en a pas parlé
en France c'est les jardins du roi
l'école nationale du paysage de
Versailles et dans les potagers du roi
parce que le Jardin du Roi c'est le
paysage à la fin c'est quoi le Jardin du
Roi monsieur Berrou en parlera mieux que
moi c'est la manière dont le pouvoir
organise et ce regard et puis c'est tout
et puis c'est tout c'est déjà beaucoup
il se regarde déjà pas mal bon et mais
vous allez ensuite c'est quoi un
paysagiste un paysagiste c'est quelqu'un
qui s'occupe de l'espace public
c'est-à-dire qu'un architecte quand il
doit intervenir sur une place sur un
bâtiment public il doit faire appel aux
paysagisticiens c'est intéressant alors
c'est peut-être une manière de répondre
sur l'Europe aussi on a des cultures
politiques qui sont comme sacrément
différents vous voyez là l'enjeu c'est
mais enfin je répondrai non je pense
qu'on a le problème c'est pas qu'on a
des grands urbanistes je pense qu'il y a
ici il y a beaucoup il y a des mers etc
on a des matchs très bien Gérard Collomb
on a des maires qui sont des qui sont
des Louis XIV
ils ont leur Jardin du Roi donc si vous
êtes directeur d'une agence d'urbanisme
vous la boucler un point c'est tout bon
je parle volontairement moi je suis
indépendant parce qu'il me permet
d'écrire là-dessus et tout en étant un
peu respecté le problème il est là on a
aujourd'hui architecte urbanisme
paysagiste c'est des gens sous tutelle
pourquoi ils sont sous tutelle ce qui
travaille pour la région il travaille
pour une mairie etc
les 10 équipes pour travailler sur le
Grand Paris il y avait rien sur la
gouvernance moi je l'ai écrit d'entrée
de jeu on ne discutait pas on dit la
gouvernance à la française c'est trop
complexe on peut pas en parler bah très
bien
très bien ce qui fait d'ailleurs tes
écoles d'architecture sont toujours au
ministère de la Culture parce que
l'architecte c'est l'artiste et les amis
de Robert sont les ingénieurs qui font
les aéroports voilà et ça on n'est pas
sorti de ça l'ingénieur et l'artiste
voilà alors les choses bougent un peu on
a depuis bon 68 quand ils ont pris mal à
laquelle tous les jeunes autour de
Castro et porte en parc et grimbach dire
ce qu'on a retrouvé dans le Grand Paris
bon c'est des gens qui s'intéressent un
peu à la ville mais avant d'employez
jamais de mauvaises jamais donc moi je
moi je vais vous dire là où ça se passe
c'est c'est beaucoup plus à l'étranger
parce que là ils sont dans un réel dure
le capitalisme est dur Colombie Brésil
c'est dur mais là ils inventent ils
inventent moi je vais faire un papier
sur un très grand architecte et à Bogota
salmonac et Moria 2 ans qui était qui
vient franco-colombien qui devrait être
célébré c'est un très grand bonhomme
ivina il vient de
l'agence de Corbusier méchamment je
dirais il avait compris ce qu'il fallait
pas trop faire
ah bah si Corbusier c'est un problème le
contexte n'existe pas le monument est à
lui-même son propre contexte c'est ça
l'architecture française ça pose un
problème ce qu'on appelle les machines
célibataires c'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas
de contact mais tout prendre de la
politique tout le problème de ces gens
partout dans le monde c'est refaire
contexte c'est se réinscrire dans un
ensemble et derrière le problème de la
métropole il y a ça c'est quoi le est-ce
qu'à Toulouse vous allez vous qui
connaissez bien ce coin est-ce que ça
peut faire métropole je dis on fait pas
métropole partout on fait pas métropole
partout tous les paysans Rio se
magnifiques et tous les gens qui
connaissent Rio c'est pas pour rien les
morts la verticale avec les favelas
d'ailleurs Le Corbusier ils ont dit du
bien maintenant comme les bistrots ils
arrivent à Rio une ville infernale une
ville infernale parce qu'effectivement
on peut pas faire ensemble on peut pas
faire une ville carte postale magnifique
et pas uniquement carte postale donc ça
là-dessus moi je on faut se bagarrer
là-dessus on a la polémique sur ronchon
était très intéressante d'ailleurs mais
je reviens pas très interne je fais un
papier dans ce numéro la polémique de
Ronchamp c'est très intéressant parce
que pour Corbusier son monument est déjà
le contexte c'est déjà le site
donc cette chef-d'oeuvre d'ailleurs
qu'appolive
j'en reviens en fait tout ça ça
mériterait des débats parce que ce
milieu moi je fréquente pas mal le
meilleur architecture urbanisme c'est
des gens très malins assez malins c'est
des gens sous tutelle un peu ces gens
intimidés et moi je trouve qu'on les il
faut les obliger à parler à c'est pour
ça qu'on s'amuse à faire cette petite
revue là et il faut les mais surtout
sans tomber dans le modèle star
architecture c'est très important et ça
se fait avec les habitants parce que
derrière c'est quoi le problème c'est
les habitants on leur demande il faut
jamais oublier quand même que nous on a
une conception de l'État social qui est
très positive mais qui quand même très
étatique qui considère qu'il y a la
volonté générale l'État et le logement
l'intérieur pour ça que aujourd'hui on
découvre tous les espaces publics le
problème des cités c'est qu'on faisait
des logements avec sous la dalle la
bagnole on a rien travaillé pour ça que
quand même c'est pas de faire sauter les
cités c'est de faire ce qu'on a pas fait
qu'il fallait faire à l'époque c'est à
dire créer des espaces publics et ça le
mon Bogota que j'évoquais c'est un type
il ne travaillait qu'en fonction d'un
espace public préalable un espace public
ça peut être trois arbres sur la
montagne d'endine ça peut être mais il
faut qu'un dehors s'il y a pas dehors
vous êtes et ça c'est fondamental je
vais vous dire il a fait la plus belle
bibliothèque qu'on voit au monde la
bibliothèque Virginie au barco en plein
bobota ville difficile pollué et cetera
il a creusé il a creusé il a fait un
parc il a mis sa bibliothèque qu'est-ce
que lui avait demandé le maire à
l'époque c'était à 25 ans vous me faites
une bibliothèque on retrouve le problème
de l'accès que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure pour des gens qui ne savent pas
lire
quand vous pose une question c'est
simple quand vous pose une question
comme ça un architecte ils savent
répondre vous allez à Lille vous sortez
de la gare la gare à l'ancienne vous
avez l'hôpital Saint-Vincent-de-Paul qui
fait un hôpital privé il y a un archer
qui a fait une rue traversante c'est
tout simple comme vous avez mais moi on
la traverse pas vraiment un Pompidou une
rue traversante c'est à dire l'hôpital
fait enclave dans le quartier lui les
gens du quartier emprunt la rue
traversante donc il voit les malades qui
eux voient les gens bien portant c'est
une révolution totale puisque les biens
voyez comme c'est un geste d'une
simplicité incroyable après faut que ça
tienne mais bon faut quand même être
formé comme architecte mais c'est des
petites choses alors ça le Grand Paris
je suis d'accord avec vous sur la
critique ça a fait bouger quand même un
peu les neurones de beaucoup de gens sur
plein de trucs faut mal là-dessus il y a
pas on n'a pas fait la grande réforme
politique etc ça on a découvert après
que il faisait bien plus de choses dans
des métropoles
non oui un peu comme bah oui oui moi je
suis assez respectueux du boulot de
Pierre Mansa à la mairie de Paris par
exemple
mais non ça a quand même fait parce que
je veux dire ces questions là on n'est
pas un pays de démocratie urbaine c'est
ça le problème n'est pas un pays de
démocratie urbaine du tout
oh vous allez être bientôt élu donc
quand même ne dites pas ça oui voilà non
et là-dessus je vais vous dire ça c'est
très important non mais vous avez raison
ce qu'on touche une question centrale et
après je m'arrête enfin j'aurais pas
répondu au dixième de vos questions je
vais prendre deux questions un qui sont
liées
démocratie représentatif démocratie
urbaine
récemment un très bon livre sur le
mondialement de l'ancien patron de l'IRD
ainsi tu recherches développement ils
vont très bien moi j'avais pas compris
mais Lula il n'a jamais on l'adore on
peut par principe il n'a jamais fait une
réforme politique parce que trop de
corruption trop de clientélisme et on
voit bien que ça lui retombe un peu
dessus et ce qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'on comprend qu'ils ont joué la
démocratie urbaine et un peu la
démocratie la démocratie urbaine Porto
Alec tous ces trucs là c'est très
important parce que qu'elle sait pas la
démocratie participative chez nous qui
est une espèce de j'ai rien contre mais
démocratie urbaine ça veut dire des
choses très très importantes là-bas mais
on voit très bien que ça se fait parce
qu'effectivement il y a cette
défaillance
représentative et après je reviens à
votre première question sur les gens à
la bordure lisez le livre remarquable du
village à la ville de ce donc Sanders au
seuil c'est très impressionnant ce que
ce qui monte nous n'est pas un pays de
l'informel ce qu'on a mis les gens dans
les cités les un peu informés lui
synthèse c'est la ville tremplin est-ce
que quartier tremplin il va se balader à
chaîne zen il va se parler à shoning il
va se balader en Inde il va il y a
toujours dans cet immense on sort de la
France on est d'accord nous le problème
c'est que les enclavés aujourd'hui c'est
ceux qui sentent des c'est ceux qui
sortent des villes et qu'on retrouve le
long des voies ferrées sauf que ça on
commence à avoir un peu les les études
nous on avait on a bossé avec les gens
de d'Emmaüs là dessus il y a le non
recours qui est un problème il y a les
invisibles les invisibles ils vont dans
les zones en plein air il y a ceux qui
arrivent à rester un peu dans les lieux
publics gare et autres parce que le fric
passe par là mais quartier tremplin ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire c'est des
espaces intermédiaires il y a la chaîne
migratoire du village de la ville donc
je vais encore un peu aider par le
village après je vais aider le village
il faut trouver je vais pas être intégré
je vais pas avoir une je vais pas les
moyens j'ai pas les moyens d'acheter un
logement au passage la rente mobilière
quand tu dis pas Axel l'économie de la
non-propriété on sait quand même
aujourd'hui tu as les chiffres mieux que
moi pour un jeune couple on met combien
d'argent de côté pour l'accès à la pro
pour acheter un logement par rapport à
notre génération
non mais moi on m'avait dit que c'est ça
c'est ça a été multiplié par trois par
rapport à notre génération c'est c'est
ce qu'on appelle la rente mobilière
aujourd'hui la rentabilité et la
question centrale moi je pense c'est une
question politique décisive je reviens
au quartier tremplin et rendre foncière
bien sûr je vais très vite il y a donc
toujours c'est le moment intermédiaire
qui peut échouer qui peut échouer quel
moment où les gens sont dans l'informel
ils ont logement informés et le problème
alors vous avez des exemples partout
dans le monde Colombie que je connais
bien Bolivie
Pérou bah il y a un moment ce qui
demande en moins de casque que les États
sont de plus en plus durs et ont moins
d'argent l'état il y a du logement
formel allez-y l'état il arrive il fait
le système d'hier c'est pas dire qu'il y
a du goudron système VR électricité et
quelques terrains ouverts
là et progressivement vous voyez que les
gens vont construire ça va faire du dur
etc et comme c'est le cas par exemple à
Istanbul aujourd'hui dans ce qu'on
appelle les GC Kondo l'état l'état il
tout d'un coup l'informel devient
propriétaire c'est l'État qui décide
c'est très important parce que ça c'est
en train de se passer un peu partout
nous on n'a pas ça du tout pour ça que
les gens sortent vont vers le Péret
urbain etc reste que c'est un colloque
sur le périurbain la semaine dernière et
grande historienne de l'urbain unifurco
disait ces petits quartiers tremplins
durant l'entre-deux-guerres on avait
partout on en avait partout il y avait
les maisons sur lesquelles on crache le
pavillonnaire les gens construisaient
leur petite bricole ils ne voulait pas
en sortir ils vivaient dans la boue et
l'État arrive 30 ans à leur amené le
goudron parce que lui il voyait l'état
la cité sociale que je méprise pas mais
qui pose des vraies questions c'est là
où on a quand même derrière tout ce
débat là on a effectivement les
collectivités la réforme on a le type
d'intervention de l'État parce que
voyez-vous même moi ce que je vois en
baladant un peu à l'étranger l'idée
d'espace public et ça n'a rien à voir
quand vous êtes à quand vous êtes
payé je connais bien en Colombie par
exemple qui est d'ailleurs joue tout sur
l'espace public c'est leur selon le
motif faire de l'espace public
médayilline la ville la plus stigmatisée
villefeuilleuse c'est la ville qui s'est
le plus transformé vous savez que des
choses très simples des enclaves un
quartier là ils ont allé chercher les
ingénieurs français mais des guides un
quartier enfin avait là très dur
métrocable c'est tous des enclavés
métrocable en deux jours ça veut pas
dire que le type a trop du boulot en
deux jours il peut sortir de chez lui
métro cab au moins nous on sait faire ça
parce que on a des montagnes et donc on
met des métros câbles c'est des trucs
mais on en a à la tonne partout dans le
monde ça c'est et ça c'est très
important des enclavé mais je reviens
sur cette idée quartier tremplin le
problème c'est pas l'état ou pas c'est
pas libéralisme ou état c'est l'État
doit favoriser des mouvements qui qui
naissent dans formelle que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est ça que je
trouve très important parce qu'après
Jean-Pierre l'a dit faut pas se tromper
le modèle aujourd'hui c'est la cité-État
c'est Singapour à Shanghai beaucoup plus
grosse ville c'est Singapour c'est la
cité fermée c'est la cité close sur
elle-même sécurisée propre fermé et ça
vous n'y accédez pas comme ça vous n'y
accédez pas comme ça donc faut bien voir
que le modèle de la ville de la réussite
que vous avez évoqué le modèle de la
ville de la Russie c'est une modèle de
ville globalisée
auxquelles tout le monde n'a pas accès
alors que le principe de la ville
c'était que tout le monde avait accès je
rappelle quand même parce que ça fait
partie de la culture que vous avez
évoqué
ce grand philosophe Levinas ce qui
rappelait ça il y avait dans le désert
d'ailleurs il y avait cette idée
pourquoi il y a des portiques qui
représentent la justice quand on se
balade au Proche-Orient dans toutes les
dans la malheureuse Syrie d'aujourd'hui
dans toutes ces villes où il est c'est
que il y a l'idée de ville refuge
on évoque beaucoup à propos des réfugiés
et tout ça veut dire que si vous avez
tué quelqu'un à volontairement dans le
désert
bon à volonté vous avez le droit d'être
jugé dans la ville vous arrivez à la
ville pour bénéficier de la justice
génial ça c'est la tradition biblique
qui est aujourd'hui dans la Torah etc la
ville ça porte des valeurs énormes et là
on revient à votre question de départ
regardez quand même depuis 89 où on
voyait quand même la démocratie plus
heureuse qu'est-ce qu'a pris de toujours
qu'est-ce qui prend dans la figure c'est
les villes l'urbicides et la question
centrale Sarajevo
pourquoi on s'en prend aux villes ça
c'est un truc que tout à fait et vous
comprenez rien au Proche-Orient même à
ce qui se passe en Syrie si on voit pas
que c'est une guerre aujourd'hui de
ville et je dis ça en ayant une pensée
pour mon ami Michel sorac est mort comme
otage et que moi j'ai ditais dans la
revue et en bouquin toute sa réflexion
sur ce qu'il appelle l'état de barbarie
ça veut pas dire que la Syrie et barbare
c'est un état qui fonctionne justement à
produire toujours de la de la violence
et de la des inst titutionnalisation
excusez-moi d'être trop long
dans la ville qui sont plutôt qui auront
plus tôt enfin qui ne pourront pas aller
vers le flux dont vous avez vous avez
exposé mais qui seront plutôt
obligés de subir l'immobilisme à savoir
toutes les toutes les résidences HLM les
résidences sociales ou malheureusement
là il faudra peut-être proposer quelque
chose pour pour rendre actif enfin pour
faire bouger cette population et puis
cette ce lieu donc je pensais aux
propositions d'écologie urbaines avec
toute cette tendance de potager
potager collectif potager solidaire donc
là c'est un peu la notion plutôt
enfin
organisation écologique qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez est-ce que c'est possible
nous avons fait à ce titre une démarche
auprès de l'Assemblée nationale et de la
commission pour auprès de Monsieur
Hérault en demandant que 20% des zones
de gazon dans les HLM soit affectés au
potager ça fait depuis quelques mois
déjà que nous avons fait ces demandes
pas de réponse comment que ça se fait
qui est si peu d'intérêt nous avons
sollicité les architectes il y a assez
peu donc d'intérêt également par contre
au niveau des collectivités Conseil
Général conseil régional ont des appels
à projets et là subventionne et
s'intéresse et font des propositions
est-ce que ça peut être une source de
solution je vois à l'école du paysage
les étudiants travaillent beaucoup sur
ces choses-là le problème qui se posent
on retrouve la métropole c'est ce que
mon petit projet ça va être mon petit
projet qui bon c'est comme la rue
piétonnière que j'ai pour moi il y a
qu'à voir les débats aux Halles etc vous
voyez est-ce que ce projet a une
signification par rapport à un ensemble
plus large c'est toujours la question
qui qu'il faut poser vous parce que les
écoquartiers c'est très bien mais vous
pouvez faire la critique des coquartiers
qui sont vite bobo-isé vous avez dans
les émirats vous avez des éco-quartiers
partout hein c'est pas ça qui ouvre
l'espace urbain
ça me permet de faire deux minutes deux
trois petites c'est très important
remarque sur
la nature ce confinement la peau évoquée
bon j'ai vu que la question du site
quand on dit qu'il y a urbanisation
généralisée ça veut dire ce que font
d'ailleurs beaucoup de gens liés à
l'écologie comme Augustin Bert Dominique
Bourg voir Nicolas Hulot ça veut dire ça
veut pas dire tout est construit mais ça
veut dire que tout est urbanisé c'est à
dire qu'il y a des effets la
désertification c'est un effet
d'urbanisation le désert il est pas en
dehors de l'urbain puisqu'il prend
d'ailleurs c'est pas pour rien que la
guerre s'y passe mais c'est pas d'une
originalité folle
mais il faut bien comprendre le
processus en cours et ça c'est très
important parce que en France le mythe
c'est de temps en temps la ville c'est
pas bien on est très anti urbain on va
revenir au village au rural alors
revient au village qu'on appelle les néo
urbains aujourd'hui très souvent vous
avez deux conceptions du village vous
allez les anciens et puis vous avez ceux
qui sont des gens un peu bien fliqué qui
effectivement seraient inventent leurs
petits villages je passe là-dessus mais
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est la
tendance générale qui est pas toujours
c'est comme les flux ça
urbanisation générale ça veut dire lisez
Jacques legoffre tant historien du
Moyen-Âge il explique que la ville au
Moyen-Âge lui parle de l'humour Banus
c'est là que ça se passe d'ailleurs on
invente la commune l'émancipation
communale donc faut quand même pas
oublier tout ça c'est très important
dans notre histoire il manque très bien
que la la ville se fait par rapport à la
campagne un peu en synergie que la
campagne se fait par la forêt lisez
Michelet la sorcière et la forest c'est
aussi la femme c'était toutes les
menaces c'est très intéressant et aussi
par rapport au désert le désert c'est le
lieu de la prière c'est le Proche-Orient
c'est très la ville c'est le commerce
l'université par rapport à la campagne
mais qui est dont on a besoin pour 1000
raisons au désert et à la forêt
aujourd'hui
on est plus à monter vers la ville c'est
ça qu'il faut arriver du village il y a
que les Français qui croient encore
qu'on peut protéger des zones
villageoises formidables ça veut pas
dire qu'il y a pas des zones formidables
c'est pas ça que je veux dire on a des
paysages magnifiques ça vaut pas les ans
mais bon ça c'est autre chose mais on a
envoyé qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'on
a un retournement sur laquelle travail
beaucoup de paysagistes d'urbanisme
comme Clément et autres mais ça c'est
une chose à expliquer c'est bien que
tous ces mots c'est pas évident là on a
un peu de temps mais ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il faut refaire de
l'urbain dans les zones rurales faut
refaire du rural pardon dans les zones
rurales urbanisées de même que la forêt
elle a été déforestée au passage nous
avons nous une grande partie la Guyane
c'est une grande partie de l'Amazonie
vous allez en Amérique latine le débat
il est toujours sur la forêt sur
l'Amazonie est-ce un bien commun elle
s'appartient etc un vrai débat après sur
la propriété justement
donc le problème c'est de reconquérir de
manière positive de la forêt du rural et
autres c'est pas de dire on retourne à
la parce que eux-mêmes ont été urbanisés
où on subit les effets d'urbanisation et
ça moi je pense que c'est très important
ce que ça c'est pigé quand vous allez au
Brésil les Brésiliens ils ont pigé ça
alors il en reste mais nous on en a je
redonne l'exemple de l'Amazonie vous
connaissez mieux tous ces territoires
montagnards et autres qui sont quand
même bon là il y a des vrais débats à
voir qu'on a jamais qu'est-ce que c'est
que l'entretien des montagnes qu'est-ce
que c'est que la forêt en France qui
sont passionnants et qui touchent
l'écologie le problème c'est pas
seulement de venir marcher dans la forêt
même si c'est très bien ça c'est juste
dernière remarque sur la ce que vous
avez dit sur les questions
urbaines je reviens à votre question là
sur cette ville je reprends pour bien
faire comprendre la notion de mon ami
Jacques Donzelot qui parle de ville à
trois vitesses ça veut dire quoi ville à
trois vitesses vous avez la ville
globaliser qu'un peu la ville on dira
bobo c'est la ville des gens moi j'ai la
chance d'habiter en centre-ville
intellectuelle très méprisante sur le
périurbain et tous ces milieux
urbanistes architectes sont en train de
changer alors
ça c'est un autre problème est-ce que on
en profite pour oublier les banlieues
comme dit certains de mes amis parce que
quand on parle du vote Le Pen il y a
aussi l'idée qu'on s'est un peu trop
occupé de ces oiseaux des banlieues et
qui serait que tant qu'on s'occupe de
nous là au confins dans les marges dans
les zones de fragilité et trois vous
avez alors ça c'est la cité à la
française vous avez pas tellement
d'exemples partout c'est pas les
quartiers tremplin vous avez
vous avez l'immobil
on nous vend du propre la ville c'est du
propre et de la propre parce que c'est
quoi la police la police grecque
polémone ça veut dire quoi pas de police
égale polémospheractite et se termine en
un peu le philosophe ça veut dire unité
dans la discorde la ville c'est l'espace
et on retrouve la démocratie j'aurais dû
commencer par ça c'est l'espace où on
pète en désaccord sans s'entretuer c'est
tout donc notre problème c'est de créer
ce type de territoire
de ce type de territoire mais voyez bien
que la question c'est la mobilité il y a
rien de pire que d'être immobile vous
pouvez être riche est un immobile
neurasthénique pour être pauvre et un
architecte que j'aime beaucoup Henri
Godin qui a fait charlétique qui a fait
plein de théâtre un très bon architecte
il disait à propos de la crise des
banlieues en 2005 si je me trompe pas
les mômes pourquoi ils sont toujours en
bas de l'escalier ils sont ni dedans ni
dehors quand on prend ça ça laisse ces
questions de rapport à l'espace c'est
finalement très simple ce que j'ai dit
sur la rue traversante le Nini là
l'espace la cage d'escalier pourquoi on
n'est pas capable de créer ces espaces
publics mieux ça c'est alors je ne vais
pas cracher au contraire j'ai montré
qu'on a nous dans la tradition française
beaucoup de beaucoup d'atouts mais que
les choses bougent un peu mais c'est des
enjeux décisifs
vous l'avez dit le problème c'est
comment trouver sa place c'est mon
problème dans le travail c'est mon
problème dans l'espace aussi
espace là aussi je joue sur les mots
space passionne mais on a des bons
latinistes là n'oubliez jamais que
espaces c'est la possibilité de se
projeter dans le temps il y a un rapport
du temps et de l'espace
space ça veut dire espoir si j'occupe
bien mon espace
je peux espérer si j'occupe mal et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on occupe mal on
n'est pas très heureux
je vais la faire rapide parce que
je ne ferai pas un grand discours donc
c'est juste à propos de la ville de
Paris on a quand vous avez parlé
plusieurs fois qui est l'exemple
justement l'intervention de l'État parce
que c'est fini Auguste qui a été le
premier en réalité à y faire de la de la
vraie du vrai urbanisme très récemment
on a vu que pour la première fois depuis
très longtemps la courbe démographique
de Paris remontait il recommence à y
avoir une augmentation de la population
qui vit à Paris est-ce que vous pensez
que ça peut être lié plutôt à la
disparition des bureaux peut-être lié
aux nouveaux usages dont parlait Robert
Rochefort aux nouvelles technologies etc
au fait qu'il y a une nouvelle façon de
vivre
collectivement au fond où est-ce que
c'est plutôt le résultat de ce dont vous
parliez à propos de la voiture du fait
que depuis tibéry en réalité on a
commencé à chasser la voiture de Paris
d'après ce que je sais je vois de temps
en temps à la mairie il y a une volonté
délibérée pas besoin d'être écologiste
de sortir la voiture de Paris top
terminé et il y aura discuter que les
chauffeurs de taxi c'est des bons
sociologues vous aurez vous aurez le
péage tout est fait pour que le
pérurbain soit coupé du centre de Paris
alors est-ce que ça veut dire que c'est
une ville bobo et autres je rentre pas
là-dedans on sait que les logements
sociaux de la nouée c'est pas de la
blague mais il y a une évolution de
Paris qui est très qui est très
problématique la région Île-de-France et
la région la plus inégalitaire d'Asie
l'avait dit à énervé la mairie de Paris
on est dans la zone la plus inégalitaire
de tout
de tout l'espace français c'est tout
c'est pas uniquement parce qu'il y a les
banlieues etc qui sont une spécificité
mais on a un très gros problème de
l'évolution de Paris qui décolle pas qui
décolle pas qui n'a pas une image forte
je rentre pas dans l'histoire Villemonde
etc et en même temps que la ville
capitale qui veut pas se décrisper bien
sûr ça doit rester une ville capitale on
est dans un pays quand même qui va pas
changer son histoire en trois jours mais
on a un problème de l'imaginaire
parisien qui est terrible en même temps
regardez une fois de plus de Grand Paris
qu'est-ce qu'on a regardé les connexions
top terminé les meilleures équipes on
sait pas occuper de l'imaginaire alors
justement moi ce que j'avais écrit
d'entrée de jeu on va pas toucher à la
et l'imaginaire au sens où je l'ai
évoqué les vitraux
si on veut que la culture politique
française change un peu et il s'agit pas
de s'opposer Girondins Jacob bon il faut
bien faire bouger l'histoire de
l'histoire bougera par la Ville de Paris
et moi j'ai tout dit pour le Grand Paris
que de toute façon c'est de la nouille
qui avait les cartes en main parce que
c'est lui qui a la ville qu'elle
l'imaginaire qu'à la force qu'elle
patrimoine un gâteau kallax qui est pas
loin là l'axe quand vous avez l'axe
napoléonien vous avez le pouvoir cette
ville est une ville monumentale de
bâtiments de pouvoir dans ton savais pas
quoi faire sinon des ministères on peut
pas s'entendre on est bien mieux dans
cette salle c'est c'est une
alors que justement aujourd'hui vous
découvrez que l'espace public il
délibère virtuellement alors je dis pas
que il faut que ça on a et que le
monument aujourd'hui n'est plus porteur
d'espace public ça c'est un autre débat
qu'on pourrait avoir ce que l'on a
travaillé dans le numéro sur reconquérir
l'espace public il faut le faire parce
qu'aujourd'hui pour moi même si ça se
passe mal ces jours-ci c'est le syndrome
de la place d'arrêt moi je connais assez
bien le Caire qu'une ville que j'adore
vu difficile vilain propre justement
mais ville pleine d'énergie parce que
moi une ville une ville c'est un truc
qui vous donne de l'énergie quand une
ville vous donne plus d'énergie quelque
chose qui va pas qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé avec les réseaux sociaux et tout
on a beaucoup déliré et Tunisie etc les
réseaux sociaux font-ils la révolution
non parce que bien sûr qu'ils ont joué
leur rôle c'est des clans des
déclencheurs formidable en Chine ils
jouent un rôle fantastique en série ils
ont joué un rôle mais ce qui est
passionnant c'est qu'à un moment là on
Egypte on a compris qu'il fallait se
rétablir où pas sur une place sur la
place arrière place difficile sur
l'agora il pour revenir à l'espace
physique mais voyez que c'est le
mouvement inverse de ce à quoi on
habitué ce qu'on enseigne à nos enfants
où on est là dans le réel on va monter
dans le virtuel pas du tout on est dans
un monde très immatériel et très
matériel en même temps les connexions et
il faut refaire il faut recréer des
territoires il y a des places partout il
y en a un pot il y en a place tarif et
la place c'est fondamentale c'est le ça
veut pas dire que ça se passe bien c'est
ce que j'ai dit il nous faut des
endroits pour pouvoir étendre des
accords sans s'entretuer c'est ça qui
fait qu'il y a des villes alors
peut-être que c'est foutu parce que les
trois tendances aujourd'hui les lieux
sont les flux sont plus fort que les
lieux on n'est plus autant de Venise et
des villes en sciatique où toutes les
villes contrôlaient les flux externes ça
c'est deuxième tendance le privé
l'emporte sur le public les
privatisations dans tous les sens du
terme
c'est-à-dire il y a une recomposition
des rapports privés publics et la mixité
perd du terrain par rapport à la
fragmentation c'est clair on est tous
pris dans ces trois tendances alors vous
allez montrer un éco-quartier vous allez
me montrer Lyon Confluence cher à
Monsieur colon on va dire c'est
formidable oui c'est formidable pour qui
le problème est-ce qu'on est capable de
réagglomérer c'est ça la question c'est
pour ça que la question de la métropole
est pas il faut la garder parce que
c'est ça qui est derrière est-ce qu'on
peut agglomérer des choses ou est-ce
qu'on va être chacun une miette une
miette le meilleur livre sur le
périurbain s'appelle la ville émiettée
il montre que c'est des miettes c'est
des miettes ça veut pas dire que les
gens sont mauvais ou quoi c'est pas la
question ou vivent mal ça veut dire que
on dit on découvre c'est une logique de
club etc etc que les gens votent moins
qu'il y a pas une application citoyenne
comme vous gardez ensemble vous la
gardez en santé on a plein de travaux
hein surtout ça vous savez vous discutez
avec un maire moins de sociologue
aujourd'hui il distingue l'habitant dans
le citoyen là où je vote l'habitant
c'est là où il y a des représentants
pour lesquelles je n'ai pas voté
agglo etc et
usager c'est ceux qui vont ben c'est
tout le débat sur Paris je rentre dans
Paris donc je profite des services etc
on est la mobilité elle fait que nous
nous avons plusieurs personnages et puis
je suis sûr qu'ici beaucoup de gens sont
un peu bi-résidentiel et pas uniquement
les hommes politiques
merci beaucoup
c'était très intéressant foisonnant
j'avais ensuite une réflexion
ultime
moi je pense que la question abordée à
différentes reprises en filigrane
c'est que au moins dans le monde qui
nous intéresse il y a précisément pas
d'urbanisation s'il y a pas de
démocratisation or la démocratisation ça
commence si on identifie la communauté à
laquelle on appartient
c'est-à-dire que je me souviens de ces
gains triomphant le jour de la Noé a été
élu
enfin le seul élément triomphe qu'il
avait il avait fait à Paris plus de voix
que la Noé c'était de la nuit qui était
élu parce
scrutin puzzle
complètement insularisant des quartiers
et il y avait pas de hors la question de
qu'on est en train de vivre de cette
espèce de labyrinthe de collectivités
locales dans lesquelles plus personne ne
se retrouve nulle part
plus la métropolisation actuelle moi je
trouve très intéressant ce que Mercier
que l'on font ensemble d'abord ça me
fait rire parce que c'est pas un grand
secret de dire aujourd'hui que Mercier
m'avait fait une grosse guerre amicale
parce que j'avais manifesté de
l'indulgence pour colon à Lyon et pour
nos amis qui rejoignaient qui au
deuxième tour on rejoint Colomb et merci
était très fâché que que et puis
finalement il fait avec colon alors
sans qu'il y ait eu des Bains sur ce
sujet
il fait quelque chose
qui est un objet nouveau non identifié
qui est extrêmement intéressante parce
que c'est je crois un objet politique
qui peut être reconnu par les gens
alors on n'a pas les institutions on n'a
pas le mode de scrutin n'a pas la
capacité on sait pas lui donner un nom
on ne sait pas rendre compte de la
cannibalisation entre métropole
département région alors
merci il était président du Département
donc d'une certaine manière il règle
cette question mais j'imagine que Keran
il doit avoir la fumée qui sort par les
oreilles
parce que
si tu fais en Rhône-Alpes la métropole
Lyon du Grand Lyon
et ben qu'est-ce qui reste à la région
alors ce n'est pas le cas Singapour
c'est pas le cas bon on voit on voit
bien que le l'identification de la
communauté à laquelle on appartient et
la première étape de la démocratisation
sans ça qu'est-ce qui se passe en France
oh c'est très simple tout élection de
collectivités locales et transformée en
élections politiques en sondage grandeur
réel sur le gouvernement est-ce qu'on
est d'accord ou pas
et aucun débat possible je voudrais vous
ici vous êtes vraiment les mecs les plus
les filles aussi
la communauté la plus élaborée sur
ce qui se passe en politique je voudrais
que vous m'expliquiez sur quoi travaille
actuellement la région Île-de-France
je suis sûr que personne ne peut dire
quelle est l'agenda de la région
Île-de-France
oui ben
il y a le Steve
mais
à une exception près
bon donc c'est c'est tout à fait
intéressant parce que dans ces
problématiques foisonnantes
voilà les voilà les questions qui se
posent et qui pose les questions qui
sont celles du civisme
pas seulement de l'urbanisme mais du
civisme c'est à dire du citoyen dans la
cité et ça pour nous ça nous intéresse
beaucoup raison pour laquelle nous
étions très heureux d'accueillir à
Olivier Mangin et pas seulement la jeune
femme vient de partir pour répondre que
chaque fois qu'on parle des potagers
communautaires si on s'adresse à des
grosses légumes il y a assez peu de
chance qu'on ait des réponses merci
beaucoup
on se retrouve le
12 février
et on accueillera Jean-Christophe Rufin
de l'Académie française de l'Académie
française